là on est dans la cuisine mais qui rit
bon voilà il ya un petit plan de travail
sympa hein c'est du beau plan de travail
donc on va faire une petite pizza
d'accord mais cherry aurait comme en
italie
et pour être dans la restonica lien qui
est ce qu'on met bien entendu on met un
petit peu de musique italienne
allez à votre avis je vais mettre quoi
je crois que je me mette retenti j'aime
être un petit je vais mettre un petit
felice talent que j'ai préparé un petit
félicita de felice dan
on a cause a dit plus haut de laquelle à
l'appel à la paix digital
allez c'est parti bon j'ai pas aimé à ça
j'ai plein de choses à vous raconter un
j'oublie tout de suite voilà on va être
temps sont jusqu'à 21h15 j'ai plein
d'imagés chocs d'arca sais pas
alors oui la peur en même temps que moi
c'est la pizza est prêt à faire avant
[Musique]
sociétale on a condamné fait bon alors
les cherry pour la pâte à pizza but où
poser poser de telles questions
c'est très simple pour la boîte à pizza
il faut 300 g de farine de froment bas
donc c'est ça les prépare issard la
farine le pronom bim bam c'est très bon
c'est magnifique
3 cuillères à soupe d'huile on a l'âge
et d'huile d'olive la mêlée talent c'est
du moins une demi 1/2 tube de levure de
bière regardées je les ai mis là dedans
voilà ça va pas boire un bon ces
conneries une cuillère à café de sucre
voilà l'appel cuillère à café l'a dit
être un petit peu plus que j'aime y ait
une pincée de zen et on va alors pour
faire la pâte
cette fin on va on va faire beau matin
la pâte alors on va la faire la pâte
elle est où cette plaque à bâbord l'île
de merde alors ouais donc bon jolie pour
la pâte
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est chez
moi je vais acheter tout fait pour
l'argent je vous expliquais donc voilà
la pâte
ouais voilà et après ouvrière voilà ça
c'est une pâte là on pouvait faire et si
rien est atteint
s'il n'ya pas une autre je vais essayer
de prendre une autre patte ce qu'on
n'est pas bien
bon ça c'est pas bon alors je vais vous
faire la pâte avec la pâte
après cela je vais leur mettre de petit
côté on n'a pas eu notre pote la merde
bon on est dans la merde donc je vais
faire avec ça chauffe et tout ça vous
inquiétez pas ça va passer voyez brûlé
dans la mer un élan à bien
bon alors vous mettez la pâte la kaaba
qu'un je suis content mais au delà
bon voilà donc je vais prendre cela
hockey parce que la pâte
elle est bien faite ok mais chéri bon on
va faire la pâte ensemble par exemple ça
va être un fiasco cette histoire de
cuisine aux folies j'ai pas qu'ils
dînaient depuis dix neuf cent soixante
dix sept ans que j'avais fait des
pédales arabi attaquant vous dire ça
s'était très bien passé bon alors là
comment je fais donc là là je fais comme
as regardé voir
voilà donc là vous d'acheter peut-être
la pâte
voilà toute façon c'est de la pâte et du
sucre paraître la pâquerette une traite
et vous mettez du sud dessus c'est pas
plus compliqué le plus important
qu'annoncé la musique pour se croire en
italie ensuite dans la recette de ma
pizza c'est très simple couvrez la patte
de sauce tomate à l'oncle de vitaly d'un
passé simple sauce tomate vous en aviez
tac
alors ça dépend si vous voulez double
sauce tomate pour une simple sauce
tomate
vous allez voir voilà meilleur âge la
robe beige l'armée mais ça passe vite
ces conneries c'est parti donc la voie
là vous mettez je vous le faire un voile
à regarder pour ça c'est de la pâte 1
c'est du bon tout ça j'en met un petit
peu plus ok on fait comme ça
wahaha ont beau gosse voilà voilà un qui
depuis dix ans en bien il ya un conte
qui m'appelle pendant sur l'antenne en
numéro masqué voilà les chéris ça c'est
bien à mes yeux et je suis content ah
non non c'est bon je me demande si
j'aurais pas dû mettre le fromage avant
on va voir ce que ça donne cette affaire
ensuite le fromage bien entendu et comme
ça là voilà comme ceci voilà voilà comme
ça est le geste comme ça voilà un beau
gosse la voilà si voilà fait des
cheetahs voilà voilà ça c'est du bon
ensuite je mette un peu de trash et
mettre un peu sec
elle peut faire comme ça faisait le sel
pullback comme ça ok tac derrière faut
faire comme ça avec les olives en voyez
le geste il est pas mal voilà c'est
comme ça qu'on fait bim bam
voilà tac ok ça c'est moche voilà donc
la la pizza bon elle à peu près près
franchement bon délire peut-être est un
peu d'huile d'olive travaux voilà
qu'elle est belle lac et bella voilà un
petit peu de poivre
voilà voilà voilà un petit peu de poivre
voilà un petit peu de toi voilà et on va
alors là maintenant il faut allumer à
lui et four allumé alors le four
donc là il ya marqué 0 l'a donc là ça
doit pas être bon là là là à mon avis là
il faut allumer et après à lui et à aa
il ya marqué chaleur tournante
économique ou chaleur tournante
geagea mettre l'économie chaleur de
voûte plus de sol comprends pas ça c'est
que ces conneries de chaleur de voûte
plus entière de sol curieuse et j'aime
être à chaleur tournante et coût 170
degrés je vais le meta et ils veulent
mettre à 200 trompe 230 c'est bien ce
sont 30 seniors à tête un maïs gm et à
265 265 c'est bien pour la pizza et
ensuite la pizza vous la laissez trois
jours dans le four trois jours ci à barr
garder ça tourne barré parce que sa
chaleur tournante
donc là je le mets là
voilà amiens quel bordel en chine
j'arrive pas médecin [ __ ] de mire
voilà voilà voilà date la pizza sainteté
dans le four on l'a plus qu'à attendre
quinze minutes et chérie et on va avoir
le goût de la pizza est ce que ça donne
[Musique]
oui on est en direct de ma cuisine là
les amours mal manger vu un gars
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions il ya un
point qui me dit dois tu vas pas manqué
de nutella et de kinder welsh paf on la
tue la pâte à tartiner l'apartheid
carton chez moi j'ai une bonne nouvelle
la pizza est prête regardez hervé les
mecs c'est papa qui a fait ça
regardez voilà irem les auriez qui sont
découpées tout seul dans le pur et ouais
les gars j'ai une fonction spéciale
bitumée y arrives il te la coupe en
petit morceaux quoi on va pas se mentir
j'ai menti préfère vous le dire et je
les ai vus en fait j'avais pas le four
et j'avais pas lancer le programme parce
que c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je fais un truc c'est quand même un
sacré abruti donc il faut que je relance
la pizza je vais la mettre
il part il faut se la mettre à 250
degrés alors voilà voilà
et après j'ai pas qu'il faut je façon on
est dans la mer on est dans la merde on
va voir normalement là c'est bon faut
voir si ça s'éteint pas c'est bah ouais
c'est bon là dedans tout est mort bah ça
répond pas donc ça m'a l'air très bon
les shihri on verra ce qu'il va donner
cette pizza là je vais manger c'est là
ce soir là ni là et on goûtera c'est là
dans un instant si c'est bon